bassem bonjour vous êtes actuellement à
tunis en tunisie donc les mesures se
multiplient sur place c'est bien ça
effectivement pierre en tunisie au
maghreb ou dans le reste de la planète
les gouvernements essaient tant bien que
mal de contenir cette pandémie de
coronavirus le premier ministre le chef
du gouvernement tunisien a même fait une
allocution où il a invité la population
à rester confinés donc c'est un
confinement générac été déclarée en
tunisie certains secteurs peuvent encore
tout de même travailler une liste même
était intéressé qui est accessible sur
le site du gouvernement tunisien mais
les déplacements sont vraiment limités
et contrôlés par la police millièmes un
couvre-feu qui a été mis en place et ce
à partir de 18h et le gouvernement a
aussi pris des mesures économiques il a
voulu se montrer rassurant pour la
population tunisienne
une enveloppe a même été être débloquée
de 2500 milliards millions de dinars
l'équivalent de 800 millions de dinars
pour venir en aide aux personnes qu'ils
vont obliger d'être en chômage partiel
et à tous les foyers qui sont
vulnérables
ici en tunisie avait également un
renforcement du budget du ministère de
la santé pour pallier à tous ces
problèmes dans les hôpitaux à tous ces
patients mais qui affluent dans les
hôpitaux tous les jours dans les entoure
de 11h 11h30 le ministère la santé fait
un point presse pour tenir informé de la
population sur le nombre de contaminés
le nombre de décès pour l'instant on
compte 75 contaminées en tunisie et
trois décès c'est moins que comme à gré
donc la tunisie et c'est de se maintenir
les autorités font le maximum pour
essayer de contenir cette pandémie
comme vous l'avez dit l'île de djerba a
été complètement isolé est fermée elle
fait partie des quatre foyers
épidémiques déclaré en tunisie avec
notamment trois autres communes de la
banlieue nord de tunis notamment la
marsa et notamment les berges du lac
la commune dans laquelle je me situe
pourquoi ces communes car c'est des
communes qui sont habitée
majoritairement par les étrangers des
expatriés est la commune à laquelle je
me situe les berges du lac est une
commune qui m
où énormément d'ambassade son siège
d'énormément d'ambassade ici en tunisie
donc des personnes qui sont amenés à se
déplacer énormément ce qui a favorisé un
petit peu le le développement de ce
virus
ici en tunisie ben ça vous commenciez à
tout à l'heure à en parler
vous êtes actuellement à tunis mais
est-ce que vous avez des nouvelles
concernant la situation dans les autres
pays du maghreb l'algérie et le maroc
effectivement pierre c'est la même
situation chez les voisins tunisiens que
ce soit au maroc ou ce soit en algérie
tunisie est passée au stade 3 c'est le
même cas pour l'algérie qui est passé au
stade 3 comme la tunisie vous aviez dit
tout à l'heure que la tunisie était le
pays dans le maghreb et qu'il est plus
critique c'est pas tout à fait ça
puisque l'algérie a atteint le nombre de
17 morts avec 201 contaminé le
gouvernement algérien a mis en place un
confinement dans le pays en limitant
tous les déplacements pour essayer de
contenir cette cette pandémie de vih
même passé au stade 3 il avait fermé
déjà toutes ses frontières bien avant
ses voisins du maghreb il a fermé ses
frontières et nc frontières terrestres
même situation au maroc où les
frontières également sont fermées ou un
confinement a été déclarée et tous les
déplacements sont complètement limité le
maroc compte 115 contaminé jusqu'à
présent avec un 4 décès enregistrés ces
pays du maghreb que ce soir malgré ce
faux dans le reste du monde
tous les gouvernements essaient de c'est
une course contre la montre s'est
vraiment de contenir cette pandémie dans
la mesure où on n'a pas encore atteint
le pic l'objectif à présent en tunisie
comme dans le reste des pays du maghreb
c'est vraiment de ralentir cet apport
dénis également espère bien pouvoir le
faire grâce à ce confinement si la
population bien sûr respecte ccc ccc
indications de confinement la police
continue à faire des contrôles et
contrôler les populations dans la rue
pour savoir pourquoi il se déplace on
limite vraiment le déplacement au strict
nécessaire savoir l' acheter à manger
aller chez le médecin ou encore à la
pharmacie mais comme je vous ai dit un
point presse devrait avoir lieu dans les
alentours de 11h 11h30 et on ne pourra
en savoir davantage sur la situation
vraiment en 1 heure et 6 en tunisie
merci beaucoup bassem chimie pour toutes
ces précisions bassem chebi donc en
direct de tunis